[Music]
and in an update
on gabby potito
oh we never did a recap
what was the last thing we had talked
about the last thing we talked about was
her just being missing no the encounter
they found him he was missing he's dead
now yeah did we talk about we haven't
talked did he commit suicide
is this what the story is about right no
it's not that oh he shot himself did he
yeah that's the forensic is that he went
whoa they found him in a swamp right
yeah
well gabby potito's family is now suing
brian laundry's parents oh
what
oh cause they knew because that was a
suspicion they claimed that they wasted
they claimed that they helped him like
oh he's over there but they knew where
he was yep gabby peter's family are
suing brian logie's parents accusing
them of knowing he had killed their
daughter before gabby's body was
eventually found and trying to help him
flee authority is that a civil or
criminal suit what's the what's the
legal difference on that one civil is
like people-to-people criminal is when
the government is charging you and that
sounds simple yeah it sounds silly
because it's the parents right civil's
basically for money criminals basically
for jail yeah
this looks like a civil suit i see their
22 year old daughter and her fiance
laundry 23 had been driving around
national parks in the us in their van
when she was reported missing by her
family in september last year potato's
body was later found on september 19th
in grand teton national park in wyoming
oh i'm trying to go there
really is it beautiful it's beautiful
that's where people die apparently oh
okay wyoming's pretty nice though it's
beautiful remember i was sending you
like the the road trip yeah i want to do
that one i want to go to yellowstone
and then it said you have to check out
grand heaton right next to it because
it's beautiful yeah there it is that's
why they were there because weren't they
they were travel bloggers right yeah
that was their content so she she was uh
the coroner revealed she had died of
strangulation just catching everybody up
laundry was a person of interest in the
homicide of his late partner and went
missing himself on september 14th
laundry's body was found on october 20th
and a forensic anthropologist determined
the cause of death to be suicide the fbi
concluded that laundry had strangled
petito after a notebook containing
confession to the murder discovered by
his remains in florida's
maya kahachi creek environmental park
whoa
and now potato's parents are now seeking
at least 30 thousand dollars in damages
from laundry's parents christopher and
roberta laundry you know what's kind of
scary is that like most the time they
wouldn't uh pursue this if they didn't
have like good enough evidence there
might be something in his confession in
the book that puts the parents out that
was my question for you is there
anything what do you mean like he made
he has a journal he he confessed like
it's so dope that my dad was like
helping me out yeah thanks dad
my parents really do love me you know
when they say blood is thicker than
water they were the only ones that
helped me get away i wanted to turn
myself in but they said nah kill
yourself somewhere else
[Laughter]
they do have to admit though that's some
down-ass pair thanks for telling them i
went left when i went
too right about this case but i remember
something saying that
he was found or like one of his
destinations after was at a campsite
owned by his parents
oh wow
i think that's the same case right so
like the parents definitely i mean of
course the parents aren't guilty of the
initial crime but they were guilty of
like hiding and abetting and oh
that was the narrative the whole time
that was the narrative is that they were
hiding well you know i mean if you guys
were parents would you give your kids up
because i wouldn't i think it would
depend if he choked out his girlfriend
for you i would send my kid in bro yeah
like i mean
you have a son kill this girlfriend
would you would and
he came home he was like hey dad i can't
believe what happened i [ __ ] killed
my girlfriend what do you do
i'd be like how the [ __ ] did you do it
first because if it's i can't believe
what happened i killed her it's like
it's like i accidentally hit her with my
car or something like that no he's like
she pissed me off she's [ __ ] so i
strangled her [ __ ] strangled her and
you better hurry up dad because don't
you hear that
yeah
if i already heard the wii u i ain't
telling him to run no no it's like it's
still like a good like 30 minutes get
the [ __ ] out of here dude
it's really far though really loud
sirens
outside credit what do you do do you try
to help them get away or you turn them
in or like what do you do
wow
that's hard it depends on how much time
they're gonna do too
because if if if it's a clear-cut casing
they're going to probably go to jail for
life i'd ask them
if they want to off themselves or if
they want me to do it wow okay so i
don't think i would go there you lenny
you hit him with the lennie vibe what if
it was your best friend that was like
hey i killed my girl help me with the
body what would you say
oh [ __ ] first of all your my best
friend's now asking me to become an
accomplice yeah and that's [ __ ] me
but he but you guys might get away with
it so just be guilt
i don't know if i could do it really
hear that mic song
you're on your own mike that was the
setup no because it was remember i don't
know if you know this story there was a
dancer um who like she
she was a dancer in la and then she
moved to vegas she um ended up in a
relationship with this cirque guy like a
cirque du soleil dude watch out for them
cirque du so he ended up killing her and
then uh
michael jackson won i forgot which one
it was it sounds like a car kind of guy
i like oh
it might be a car kind of sounds more
like a zoom and you do typically it yeah
but he killed he killed his girl asked
his best his roommate to help with the
body and he his roommate [ __ ] helped
him
whoa but did he did the roommate like
help because of the awkwardness
situation while also calling the cops
like silently yeah you know what i mean
no he didn't he was just a straight up
ride or die homie
but they did a lot of weird [ __ ] they
[ __ ] they chopped her up they put her
in cement in the bathtub jesus christ
why is it always cement in the bathtub i
don't know people think that [ __ ]
works yeah that's super dexterous yeah
that's
if your homie comes and tells you right
hey i killed someone please help me
um and like let's say you go don't
[ __ ] talk to me don't even put me in
this position and you cut off all
contacts
the fact that you now know but you don't
report it are you considered a conflict
or like you know are you can it be
charged not if you call you guys
run away the only way yeah
[ __ ]
damn that's some good foresight so like
as soon as you hear a crime if you don't
report it you're technically guilty a
little bit of something well like
something like that no there's a charge
with that
right because it's um isn't there
something where like if you tell your
wife or your husband it's like that
doesn't count in court because they
can't testify against yeah there's that
there's a thing if you're married you
can't you can't force them to testify
they can do it voluntarily but they
can't before so that means if my son
comes to me and he's like yeah i'll kill
this person help me i'd be like marry me
right now yeah but if people do that
marry me right now and then we'll talk
because then you'll never know what the
other person knows that solves that
problem that's just how far that's the
ride or die i gotta do you gotta hey
there's some legal [ __ ] to this first
i'd rather just be gay
so this lawsuit claims that they had
quote full knowledge that gabriel potido
had been murdered by their son alleging
that they hid his this knowledge from
authorities while the search was
underway
quote it is believed and therefore a
averred that
brian laundry advised his parents
christopher laundry and roberto laundry
that he had murdered gabrielle petito
states a lawsuit
on that same day christopher laundry and
roberto laundry spoke with attorney
steve bertolino and sent him a retainer
on september 2nd 2021 oh
that's the [ __ ] thing the receipt
because they had already paid for a
lawyer before the [ __ ] thing was
found out and i heard i heard they were
also getting in trouble by the the state
as well for
[ __ ] around with the resources of the
search and they were once again like
pointing in wrong directions so i heard
that the state was trying to prosecute
them as well so the legal filing goes on
to say while joseph petito and nicole
schmidt were desperately searching for
information concerning their daughter
christopher laundry roberta laundry were
keeping the whereabouts of brian laundry
secret alleging that they were making
arrangements for him to leave the
country damn oh wow
christopher and roberta laundry
exhibited extreme and outrageous conduct
which constitutes behavior under the
circumstances which goes beyond all
possible bounds of decency and is
regarded as shocking atrocious and
utterly intolerable in a civilized
community the lawsuit adds yeah man
this is also weird because we're not
human enough to like know these
situations until we get there but
i think a best friend it's like that's
one thing yeah but you're you're a kid
your child is i don't know i think for
my kid if
if it's like a crime against like a
person
and i feel like it's justified i'd
probably help him get away but if it's a
crime against humanity i'd probably kill
him
that's what i said and people were like
that's dark cause i'm like i'm like
that's your okay so first of all but
then now you have a crime on your head
yeah it's fine
my generation's dying is that double
jeopardy no no no i think that's a
double homicide pythagorean theorem i i
i think like you know whatever you
create
it's your it's your responsibility right
so if i create a human being and even
though they have their own you know
ideas and what they're gonna do and they
might be an absolute hitler and they'll
go out there and do whatever but i feel
like well i brought them in so maybe i
should take them out and then so uh
because i'll feel the guilt and
responsibility of like maybe i didn't
parent well maybe whatever it is uh [ __ ]
it you know maybe i should go to jail
too maybe you'll feel the guilt and
responsibility of killing your kid that
too but but ultimately it's your party
he's a hitler
or if he or she lost their temper and
murdered someone right then that to me
is like a crime against humanity it's
not something that it's like you know
they it's like i'm gonna help you escape
because it's like like let's say the
laws after you and it's like one of
those like in the movies where it's like
oh [ __ ] the government framed you or
like something's happening and or like
in self-defense you had to murder
someone or whatever right and i'm like
but the evidence is stacked against you
and only we know this secret it's like
okay now i'm gonna send you to mexico
you know what i will say though
when i look at a court case like this if
uh his parents lose the case and the
only thing that happens to them
is their fine 30 grand i'll [ __ ] do
it every time
you know what i mean
like if that's if that's really like the
only thing at risk
this is like the case study and you
extrapolate every other situation after
then it's like oh it's dirty g's yeah
it's like i was like kill anybody you
want i'll help you yeah
exactly you know what i'm saying because
that's your own kid too like i i do get
that that's very emotional and very
difficult and there's already like is my
kid a good kid if he's a good kid i
might try to help if he's a bad kid i
might put him down whatever but at the
end of the day you're like what's my
personal risk for like trying to help my
child a thirty thousand dollar lawsuit
[ __ ] you take it yeah that's it does it
run that way
like how [ __ ] up our justice system is
actually you have 30 grand sit down [ __ ]
it 30 grand no big deal call it a day
and like that's it that's
for what they did you know if they if it
comes out that's like rich molesters and
stuff like that yeah that's true huh
slap on the wrist you're free to go it's
like that recent case with the ufc
fighter who got revenge on the molester
right so like the molester is probably
not gonna do as much time as he does for
for trying to uh protect his daughter
yeah protect his daughter
yeah and and that's i think that's
what's weird the justice system is so
like case by case that it just doesn't
feel right when you see somebody that's
like getting away with the slap on the
wrist well the other person is like and
the other person did it like a hundred
times and it's probably gonna get away
with a few years and the other person
was protecting the daughter is like put
away from [ __ ] life or some [ __ ]
that's crazy so how is that so this 30k
that's in um reimbursement to the city
for using its resources incorrectly
based on their things this is i think
this was just between the parents the
two parents different yeah it says is
now seeking 30 000 in damages from
laundry's parents oh from the money they
spent trying to find and like you think
like because how they come about that
number is very specific right like i'm
sure there's a system that they have in
place but it is like how do you come up
with that number like why only 30 000
maybe they just have to show expense
reports on what they spent trying to
find maybe like i don't know they put
money out for
extra searchers or some [ __ ]
but then what i thought they would in a
civil suit you can't do punitive or like
pain and suffering and [ __ ] like that
that's only you can you can only do that
in criminal or what
i don't even know because then those are
the ones you're like how did you come up
with that number where it's like oh like
the damage emotionally yeah you killed
my dog 50 million dollars yeah i don't
know how they come up with punitive
[ __ ] pain and suffering that's crazy
oh